foreign
[Music]
hi good afternoon everyone thank you for
making the choice to see this session
despite it being a lunch hour
we're going to talk about a whole lot of
things of course confidential Computing
and we've moved through the encryption
Trifecta encryption at rest and then
moving on to encryption and news which
is confidential Computing and then we're
going to talk about some new product
announcements and subsequent to that
confidential space and the Privacy
sandbox
my name is Sam lugani I look after
confidential Computing in Google cloud
and with me is Jenny who's the PM lead
on confidential space and Christina
who's going to talk about the Privacy
sandbox she leads that space
um great so privacy and security are
centered to how we design products and
it's the same for our customers as we
speak to our customers often enough
these things are top of mind for them as
part of this session today we're going
to present some scenarios that come up
very often in our conversations with our
customers
and give you a blueprint on how to
approach these for your own organization
this session is going to be a little
different there's a few slides but
there's a bunch of demos interspersed as
we look at those blueprints
so one of the first things that comes up
in every customer conversation is the
idea that they want the highest level of
protection for their keys
and that's especially true if you have
data that you can't anonymize or
tokenize so what's the answer there it's
encryption at rest
and we have a few options when it comes
to encryption addressed you can have a
cloud a cloud hosted key management
system or KMS where you can store keys
in inner cloud service you can rotate
destroy
create new keys as part of that process
you can also have an HSM by your store
and do all cryptographic operations
within a Hardware security module that's
especially true if you have regulations
that you have to work around or specific
compliance requirements so if you need
an HSM that's fips 3.0 certified that's
the way to go and then of course if you
want to create separation between where
your keys are stored and where your data
is that's where an ekm comes in where
this is a third party system that's
deployed up outside of Google's
boundaries
so let's take a quick peek at a demo as
to what this looks like in our console
um can we skip can we yeah perfect
great so I'm logged into Pantheon which
is a Google Cloud console within this
I'm going to create a new instance type
and as I'm creating this new instance
type there's a few options here and I
see boot disk now as I move over to this
boot disk I can look at the different
configurations I have and there's a few
encryption options there's of course
default on Google managed encryption key
but in this case we actually want to
have a key that's managed by the
customer so I can click on CMAC I can
look at the keys that I have created
earlier that are available to me or I
can enter a key manually as well so in
this case I'm going to choose a
symmetric key that I've added in already
and that's about it I can select this
and I can create a new instance type
that is associated with that key now
what happens though if
multiple instances associated with the
same key and I as an admin want to have
more control over what happens with
those instances so I have a dashboard
where I can look at all these different
keys that I've created in this key in
this case there's a key called CC test
and I've disabled that key for now what
that would mean is that any instance
that's associated with that kind of key
should not actually boot up and that
gives me more control as an admin so
let's see if that works um I have this
cmec CC instance type and it is
associated with the key which we've just
disabled so I'm going to try and start
this instance type
and as I'm starting this instance cyber
doesn't get booted up and the reason is
because as an admin I've disabled that
specific key that's associated with this
instance type and that gives me a lot of
control to do specific things within my
organization can we move back to the
slides please
all right
so now that you've figured out what you
want to do with data at rest encrypted
based on an encryption scheme that works
for you what's the next step in that
Journey you've got to do something
useful with that data if it's sitting in
a place and not doing anything it's not
sort of making money for you so you've
got to do something useful with it which
is that you want to bring it into an
instance type or a container and have an
application work on that data but before
you bring it in you want to make sure
that that container is hardened against
a bunch of things and that's where a
shielded portfolio comes in we have
shielded VMS and shielded GK nodes
enabled by default which is a big deal
now there's three key elements there
there's a vtpm a virtual trusted
platform module which looks at your
pre-boot sequence there is integrity
monitoring which looks at your runtime
boot sequence and then there's a third
element called secure Boot and what that
means is that if anything is out of
order in your boot sequence your
instance will not boot up and this is
what would protect you against boot kits
rootkits and kernel level malware and
it's enabled by default
so you you had your encryption address
figured out you have this hardened VM
system what if you need more
ah
what if you need more confidentiality
and more isolation around your data
that's where confidential Computing
comes in so confidential Computing
provides a verifiable way to guarantee
isolation within specific boundaries in
a confidential environment
oftentimes we talk about what
confidential Computing is you know we
have a small crowd so human be a bit
we'll try and sort of visualize what
that could mean in specific situations
so imagine you know I'm at a bank in the
60s That's My Monopoly manhat and I'm
walking into a bank there's tele
services available we all have a swim
Lanes that's my briefcase with that nice
Google Cloud logo encryption at rest all
boxed in and I have my keys in my wallet
so as I walk into the teller there's
different swim Lanes there's multiple
tellers all around I'm opening this box
and I'm getting some gold coins out
maybe I'm exchanging some pii as well
now although there are these swim Lanes
if there is someone well inclined to see
what I'm doing they could potentially
Peak and figure out what I'm doing here
and we don't want that we want that
extra level of confidentiality so now
imagine the same bank and a world inside
that bank and I walk into that world and
do some of these transactions
so we don't have a world here but we
have this nice
Cloud umbrella so we're going to treat
this as our world right now
I'm walking in to this world
doing my transactions
taking some chocolate out because you
know it's lonely here it's isolated
quite it's quite well isolated here and
taking out a few gold coins as well
because apparently coffee is pretty
expensive in San Francisco
so I'm doing all these transactions in
closing my box and walking out and as
I'm doing these transactions my
transactions are protected
there is a higher degree of
confidentiality
as as I'm going through this process
that is guaranteed isolation and there's
verifiability which is where attestation
comes in which gives you this assurance
that the environment is secure and has
not been altered
and this is how this is how we look at
confidential Computing now
when we started this journey of
confidential Computing about three years
back
there were a lot of options in front of
us
to get rid of this head by the way but
uh there were a lot of options in front
of us
and as we spoke to customers one thing
was loud and clear
that customers don't want to compromise
between having to make a lot of changes
in their workloads or choosing more
confidentiality so the way we've
designed this system is that if you're
looking at confidential Computing and
adopting it there's no quote changes
that's required you can bring your
applications as they are two VMS or two
containers without any code changes
because that was loud and clear three
years back
and we're maintaining that approach as
we move forward
the other thing which customers brought
to us was that look
performance is money we want to make
sure that as we are sort of going the
confidential Computing route we're not
you know we're not compromising on
performance
and we spent a lot of time with our
partners engineering how this would work
really well and seamlessly so the
performance impact for confidential
Computing on gcp is absolutely minimal
we have performance briefs we can happy
to that we're happy to share with you
now confidential VMS are very similar to
regular VMS there's no code changes
again required and a question we get
often is where are the keys the keys are
in that secure processor they're
generated by the processor they handled
by the processor and the memory
controller gets access to them
wherein it can decrypt data put it in
the cache and that with the CPU can
execute the instructions coming from the
application
these are ephemeral Keys generated by
Hardware Google or even any customer
would not have access to those keys
so we've taken this base
confidential VM concept and we've
extended to a lot of different products
so now we have confidential VMS
we have confidential GK nodes no code
changes lift and shift no perform
minimal performance impact rather
and we have confidential data proc and
data flow
which means that if you have
streaming analytics requirements and you
want to do processing based on batch
jobs you can do that within data flow
all within dataproc if you're dealing
with Hadoop and Spark clusters that are
managed now you can process a bunch of
those things within a confidential
environment
and of course there's confidential space
that Rene is going to talk about in a
bit
so let's move over to the Dem
I I want to show you how easy really how
trivially easy it is to create a
confidential VM so again I'm logged into
a Pantheon I'm going to create an
instance
there's this magical enable box right
here
now the moment you click enable there's
a bunch of stuff which is happening in
the background
with automatically picking a region that
supports confidential Computing oh and
by the way gcp supports confidential
Computing in more than 80 percent of its
regions globally which is more than any
other cloud provider
we're picking
um an image that is supported by a
confidential Computing and we support a
vast number of images
and we're also picking the right
configuration that will support this
process so all you got to do is click
this enable button within when you're
creating a new instance type now when
you go to kubernetes the process is very
similar you will create pick a standard
cluster
and go to security and then you got it a
single checkbox that can create a
confidential GK cluster so any nodes
within this cluster going to be
confidential as well or you can have
specific nodes which are confidential in
an existing cluster so we give you that
flexibility
and as a way to sort of check
I can execute this command I'm logged in
and it should say that the confidential
nodes are enabled as part of this
cluster so it's pretty straightforward
back to the slides please
oh can we get back to the slides please
okay great
so what's the next step in this journey
we've spent a lot of time with our
partners particularly Intel in
evaluating different platforms
as intel was working on TDX trusted
domain X extensions which supports
confidential computing
orange teams collaborated with them very
closely to uncover areas where we could
further strengthen the security of their
platform
and this is not just a Google thing we
believe in confidential Computing to a
high degree and we want to make sure
that these benefits are available not
just for Google Cloud customers but for
everyone that's using confidential
computing
and so we worked with Intel closely we
published this audit at RSA where we
evaluated the system's uncovered flows
and we jointly fixed those flaws
and we continue to work with them on
their next generation of
Hardware that supports confidential
Computing so we've been working with
anil's Team over the past few years
to make sure that we expand our
confidential computing portsfolio
such that if you have workloads that are
optimized for Intel CPUs then you can
get that benefit of confidential
computing
so we are very excited to announce that
confidential VMS will soon be available
in private preview on the C3 machine
family that uses the 4th gen Intel Xeon
processors which is uh which also
supports TDX or trusted domain
extensions
now
of this is remote attestation which is
that customers will be able to verify
that they're actually in that isolated
environment
so you can sign up for this private
preview right away and this is a first
Intel based confidential VM offering the
first of many steps will take along the
way to make sure that confidential
Computing is available to a much wider
audience across the world
now the next topic we want to talk about
is how we securely collaborate with
multiple untrusted parties and to talk
about that I want to invite you any on
stage
this is fine be careful
thanks Sam uh awesome demos and great
props I didn't bring any props with me
unfortunately so I'll have to try a
pantomime or something like that but um
super excited about the Intel TDX
preview that's upcoming and overall
about our fantastic collaboration with
such amazing Partners like Intel and
more to come there for sure
but now I would like to talk about
data collaboration without data sharing
and Sam you should be asking me now
Renee what are you talking about how can
you collaborate on data without actually
sharing it right
but I'll repeat data collaboration
without data sharing specifically
and also actually retaining full data
you utility that is often lost or
diminished when various privacy
enhancing Technologies are applied and
hashing tokenization
Etc
specifically I'm talking about unlocking
secure multi-party collaboration for
teams and organizations something that
was Impractical in the past especially
if we're talking about that highly
sensitive data regulated data Phi PCI
Etc and this is where even the core
capabilities and benefits of
confidential Computing may not be
sufficient like the memory encryption
and CSP isolation
and that's why exactly we build
confidential space this is the product
that we announced last year at last
year's next conference it was a virtual
event so not nearly as exciting as this
one with us being in person and the
confidential space really helps unlock
these scenarios like a secure
multi-party collaboration
what's confidential space provides it
creates a secure environment called
often trusted execution environment or a
te or secure Enclave and that's where
only a trusted workload can access your
sensitive data and no one else even the
operator of the environment cannot
access your data
and that unlocks some really cool use
cases and I'm gonna show a few of those
to you next
okay so let's start simple we have a
data owner and we have data consumer and
a data consumer wants to gain some
insights from data owners data data
consumer also plays the role of the
processing owner or the operator of the
environment kind of makes sense they
want the inside so hence they should pay
for the processing
the data owner
keeps control over their data they
decide when and which workload through
Co through code authorship should be
able to access their sensitive data okay
so what could be an example actually of
one of those scenarios well think of a
healthcare institution like a hospital
and they have tons of that super
sensitive Phi data and a data consumer
could be a research institution and they
want to gain the insights right and even
though you can see data consumer our our
research institutions also a processing
owner it doesn't mean that they can
access data in the clear they can only
gain access to the insights
okay let's move to the second scenario
here even the data owner moved to the
right side if you can see that
um it's about ml model protection right
we're all excited about the AIML and
llms right this is my obligatory AI
mention of the presentation
um and um so and there's a there are
valid reasons for that right and some of
these models really take tens of
millions of dollars to develop and train
so obviously this is a very valuable
intellectual property for all these
companies that develop models
so they they want to make their models
available to their customers while still
retaining control over their
intellectual property
while data owners may want to consume
the model but they don't want to share
their sensitive data with the model
developer right
so this flexible architecture actually
allows the data owner to be also the
processor and hence control and keep
their data private process the data gain
the insights pay for that while the
model owner the owner of their
intellectual property can keep control
over their model so it's a true
win-win-win scenario here
okay let's move to the next one the last
one a little bit more elaborate secure
multi-party collaboration scenario here
as you can see in this case both parties
are adding data to this Mutual
collaboration and both are gaining the
insights right and this can be
competitors imagine multiple Banks
looking for fraudulent activity or
insurance companies looking for double
dipping fraud detection right can be
also Telco retail can be ad tax for that
matter
all uh adding their data their sensitive
data and at the same time getting
guarantees that their data is only
accessible by this verified approved and
audited reproducible code that they have
all agreed upon and of course this
collaboration is not limited to just two
parties this scales to multiple multiple
parties and finally you may notice that
the data collaborators don't have to be
the processing owner or the author of
the processing logic either they can
Outsource those activities to other
organizations that specialize in them
and at the same time while retaining
through remote attestation full control
over their data and knowing which code
is authorized to access their data okay
so
what is this magical product that
supports all of these scenarios and more
well again this is why we build
confidential space
this is the product we call it our
trusted execution environment gcp is TE
it's built on our very robust
confidential VM offering that's been out
for a number of years as Sam mentioned
already it supports complete lift and
shift no code modification is required
whatsoever
um we also
see that most of our customers don't
notice any performance impact when
running in confidential mode
and finally we provide full TCP IP
networking stack for this environment
out of the box finally this is all built
on Open Standards and open source code
ensuring easy product interop
a little bit more details on the
confidential space and how it's built
another tenant we had in mind when
building confidential space is usability
so it's very easy to use and set up we
provide at a station verify service for
our customers out of the box as I
mentioned we run on top of confidential
VMS and that's where we also provide
especially hardened image that removes
things like SSH and that's done to
remove the operator the admin of the
environment from the trust boundary so
that's how we achieve the operator
isolation and then you run your regular
containerized workload on top of that
and we also um provide an interface for
customers to create a very simple policy
and that's how they specify the
conditions under which they are willing
for their sensitive data to be processed
in the secure environment
and so overall it's all about ease of
use Open Standards and super easy
deployment
yeah
so last time at next when we announced
confidential space I showed you a funny
demo where multiple people imagine
colleagues or classmates want to learn
who makes more money without actually
revealing their actual salaries right so
a little bit funny example but it gets
to the point you can still find this
demo on YouTube as part of last year's
next announcement but let's um look at a
different demo this covers one of the
scenarios that I actually described in
the prior slides specifically ml model
protection
okay let's get this started
so here imagine that we have a hospital
and they want to use a cancer detection
ml model provided by another entity on
their x-rays or or CT scans
so on the screen we have kind of a front
end at our Hospital build for their use
of ml model
and and the developer of the model
allows the hospital to be to use their
model but only if it's in a trusted
execution environment that's properly
configured you know only after getting
successful attestation guarantees that
tell them that it is indeed running in a
secure environment and the operator of
the environment cannot exfiltrate their
data this way
um
so now the hospital will select that
super sensitive Phi data they want to
analyze
and then they'll click the analyze
button
it looks like actually the sensitive
data is me riding a bike in a super
secret Google office okay well let's
click the analyze and what do we see
well we have an error failed to access
the protected model please check your te
deployment configuration what happened
here so it looks like there's some issue
with the te configuration itself let's
first look at what the model owner
required from the hospital
how this T should be configured okay so
let's look at the requirements looks
like our model owner wants the their
model to be used in Te confidential
space with secure boot enabled on
special type of confidential Computing
hardware and even using this specific
image hash to be running in the te and
where these conditions submit by our
hospital and their te let's look at the
live te measurements coming from the
stressed execution environment and it
looks like the answer is no
we don't have confidential space coming
from our software name secure boot seem
to be disabled
so what happened here well it looks like
the hospital misconfigured their te it
looks like they forgot to enable a
secure boot which is one of the many
prerequisites for confidential space
but now hospital will fix their issue we
just switch to another tab where the
hospitals spun up another confidential
space te hopefully it's configured
correctly now so let's look again at the
live te measurements
and now we have confidential space great
we have secure boot enabled true perfect
and now let's even look at the hash
that's running so a model owner required
this hash and it looks like it matches
exactly what we have in this tea
so perfect now the hospital can retry
this model inference and inference of
this super sensitive and secret image we
click analyze button and the inference
will now run
let's see what it comes up with
okay inference results are in it looks
like the model can use some tuning
because I don't think it was a Bicycle
Built for Two or certainly not a
tricycle but that's besides the point
right
um so basically what we wanted to
demonstrate here is the ability for a
model developer to secure share their
model with anybody but if and only if
it's running in a specific secure
environment making sure that they keep
their intellectual property intact while
the users can keep their sensitive data
intact as well
Okay so
hopefully that was clear if not don't
worry we have plenty of amazing code
Labs on our website that give you
literally step-by-step instructions on
how to reproduce this and many other
examples with confidential space
okay so let's summarize
confidential space
pushes confidential Computing Beyond its
core value propositions and benefits
such as memory encryption CSP isolation
and unlocks these amazing multi-party
collaboration use cases across teams and
organizations
let's enabled through a number of these
key attributes on the slide basically
everything is measured and attested to
before customers share their data you
keep control over your data you know
what what code will access your data and
when and you don't need to trust the
operator either
either okay here we'll move to the last
part of our presentation and I'll invite
Christina from the Privacy sandbox team
and that's the team that uses privacy
enhancing Technologies like confidential
Computing powered trusted execution
environments to make a web even more
safe and private Christina please take
it away
thanks
thank you so much
um hi I'm Christina lavento I'm the
product lead for measurement in the
Privacy sandbox which is a collaborative
effort across Chrome and Android to keep
people's activity private across a free
and open internet
um I really don't think it's any
surprise to this audience that consumers
regulators and businesses expectations
around privacy are evolving and these
rapid changes in the Privacy landscape
have prompted businesses to think about
the long-term durability and viability
of their products and over the past
several years that we've been working on
the Privacy sandbox effort it's been
great to see the level of Engagement
from the ecosystem in privacy enhancing
Technologies the challenge of course is
that the digital ecosystem has evolved
over the past 20 plus years to rely on
third-party cookies and other persistent
identifiers to profile users and track
them as they move across the web
and mobile apps
so for example today a third-party
cookie might be used to identify a
person who has previously interacted
with a brand or Advertiser website to
later show them an ad for that Brand's
newest product or their newest release
when that person sees the ad this event
is sent back to the ad Tech with a
persistent identifier possibly from a
third party cookie and later on if that
user makes a purchase or visits the
Brand's website that purchase event or
website visit is again sent back to the
ad Tech with that same identifier which
allows the ad Tech to match up these
events and and track the user so when we
think about tasks like measuring the
performance of an ad campaign this makes
a lot of sense from a technical
perspective sending out events with
persistent identifiers as a key makes it
very easy to match and post-process this
information later
but the problem is that all of a
person's activity across many different
sites or apps can be linked in this way
which leads to many privacy challenges
so given these risks it's our view that
these persistent identifiers whether
it's third party cookie or some other
alternative identifier like an IP
address present a privacy risk that
outweighs their benefits to the
ecosystem now that being said just
bluntly or removing or blocking these
Technologies without providing a
reasonable alternative for ways to
deliver relevant advertising and measure
its performance could reduce access to
information or disrupt the services that
we all enjoy as part of the open
internet
even worse it could result in more
opaque tracking workarounds that are
even harder for consumers to observe or
control
so our aim with a privacy sandbox
initiative is to work collaboratively
with the ecosystem to develop new
privacy centered Technologies to support
the open web without relying on these
persistent identifiers and we have a
wide range of proposals new technologies
and privacy focused changes that we've
developed including ways of addressing
covert tracking creating clear
cross-site boundaries and also tools for
delivering relevant ads and measuring
their performance
now how do we do this
spoiler alert there's going to be some
confidential computing
so before I talked about how an ad Tech
might choose an ad based on a user's
past interactions with a brand or
Advertiser and then measure how that how
well that ad campaign is working using a
third-party cookie to link up their
behavior across the ad view all the way
to visiting the Brand's website
and then finally perhaps making a
purchase now with our privacy sandbox
proposals we actually take a very
different approach so instead of relying
on sending a persistent identifier
outside of the browser with each one of
these events to be matched and processed
later we Instead try to do as much of
that matching and processing on the
device as possible so for example to
measure conversion so if someone sees an
ad and then later makes a purchase the
browser can actually match those events
on the device and then before sending
that match back to an ad Tech the
browser adds noise May randomly suppress
the reports or create entirely new fake
reports to protect the user's privacy
however there are many instances where
being able to extend our computation
beyond the device actually enables us to
improve system health or actually allows
us to open up new options for different
privacy properties and better efficiency
in our Solutions
now the challenge here is of course we
can't just extend beyond the device
without having a way for the browser to
be confident that there's no outside
access to the data that we're processing
and also for the browser to certify that
the code being used to process that data
outside of the device is really the code
we intend to be using that it's actually
doing the Privacy preserving analyzes
that that we want
so to do this we naturally turn to
Technologies like trusted execution
environments and in the next couple of
slides I'll walk through two examples of
how our proposals leverage trusted
execution environments
all right so the first place that we use
trusted execution environments in the
Privacy sandbox is for aggregating
conversion reports across users this
allows us to take advantage of the
Privacy benefits of aggregation so that
we can add less noise to the results
while still protecting each individual's
browsing data the aggregation service
allows an ad Tech to collect encrypted
reports from many different users
browsers not just one at a time and then
process them to learn noisy aggregated
insights about campaign level
performance
because the service runs within a
trusted execution environment the
browser is also able to validate that
the correct aggregation and noise
addition steps are performed to
safeguard users privacy
so let's walk through a typical
aggregation workflow for conversion
measure so let's imagine that a user saw
an ad in their browser for a given ad
campaign and then later made a purchase
the browser will handle matching the ad
view to the conversion event on the
device and then creates an aggregatable
report containing the Matched conversion
data like the purchase category and
purchase dollar amount as well as
perhaps the ad campaign from the ad that
the original the user originally saw
this report is then encrypted before it
sent back to the ad Tech
now the ad tag collects these
aggregatable reports and assembles them
into batches for example maybe all of
the conversions for a given Advertiser
on a given day and then sends them to
the aggregation service
and the only way that the ad Tech can
actually analyze the contexts of those
encrypted reports is to use the
aggregation service which runs An
approved version of the aggregation
logic in a trusted execution environment
so decryption keys will only be released
to trusted execution environments that
are running an approved version of that
aggregation logic
um and so what this does is it makes
sure that the browser is able to confirm
that the right privacy preserving steps
are applied before those results are
released back to the ad Tech in a
decrypted form now measuring ad
performance is a key use case for
supporting the open Internet it's
important to know if your ads worked or
not and the scale of the problem that we
have to tackle is immense the
aggregation service can process hundreds
of millions of aggregatable reports in
one job and by leveraging this trusted
execution environment we're able to
expand the types of noise and privacy
preserving mechanisms that we use beyond
what can be applied on device alone
I now see that my problem advancing the
slides was pressing the laser pointer
sorry about that okay uh so let's let's
talk about um a second way that we use
trusted execution environments in the
Privacy sandbox and that's as part of
our relevance proposals and at the core
of our relevance proposals or proposals
for delivering relevant ads is
maintaining control of a user's interest
and browsing history on the device but
running ad auctions with particularly
sophisticated bidding and scoring Logic
on the device may present a challenge
for system health and scale in some
cases so expanding computation beyond
the device can allow ad Tech providers
to take advantage of more compute power
to identify more relevant ads without
impacting the device's system Health our
bidding and Auction Services proposal
outlines a way for client devices to
offload ad auction computation by
allowing sellers to run a seller front
end and auction services and a trusted
execution environment and likewise
allowing buyers to run buyer front-ends
and bidding services in a trusted
execution environment so let's walk
through an example
so let's say a person is using an
Android app and that app has an
available spot that they want to show
and add to the user the app will send an
ad request to uh with an encryption
auction input to the seller's ad service
now this request this encrypted request
will contain both contextual information
maybe like the category of the app and
information about the user's interests
like inference interest group
information that's normally collected
and stored on the device
um so then once the seller ad service
receives this encrypted request it then
calls a seller front-end service to
conduct the auction and it passes along
that encrypted auction input the seller
front end is running within a trusted
execution environment and then calls
buyer front-end to get bids
the buyer front end runs bidding server
to get bidding logic to run bidding
logic in a protected environment and
sends real-time signals from a trusted
key value service to actually generate
these bids
now once the seller received bids from
various buyers it calls the auction
service within a trust and execution
environment to score the bids and select
the winning ad before returning it back
to the client now the selected ad along
with the other URLs may be needed for
reporting or billing are encrypted and
can be inspected only by the client
service
so the key thing here is that the
auction input can only be decrypted in
the trusted execution environments run
by buyers or sellers which allows
legitimate buyers and sellers to use
this input to determine their bids and
determine the auction outcome but
prevents it from being shared Outside
The Trusted execution environment so
even though the user's interest signals
left the user's device by limiting
access to verified code running within a
trusted execution environment the client
device is able to offload resource
intensive auction computation without
actually leaking any of those user
signals directly to the Valor buyer or
seller in the auction
okay and this is quite different from
most systems today that actually rely on
an externally available persistent
identifier which is logged and shared
and matched across buyers and sellers
okay so now that you've seen an overview
of the privy sandbox I'll hand it back
to Renee thank you so much for having me
amazing amazing worker Christina and the
team are really hard work really
important work and really cool use of
tees right so thanks uh thanks Christina
and and in fact
um confidential space is one of the
Privacy supported tees and we already
have a number of AD techs today testing
privacy sandbox on gcp and we look
forward to collaborating with many many
more attacks as the ads world is
preparing for this change plan change of
uh deprecation of third-party cookies so
today let's wrap it up we packed a lot
in this session we had live demos we had
props we had recorded demos lots of lots
of work and lots of content but let's
summarize it first Sam gave us an update
and the State of the Union of
confidential Computing at gcp uh all the
services including dataflow and data
prerogator supported and how super super
easy it is to enable confidential
Computing as easy as clicking that
enable button that you can see at the
top left corner of your screen so give
it a try for your VMS for your gke and
other gcp services
and then
Sam also gave us an update about the
upcoming Intel TDX preview the latest
and greatest in confidential Computing
from Intel so scan the QR code if you're
interested in the middle of the screen
and sign up for the preview
then we also discussed
confidential space that unlocks these
cool use cases like ml model protection
secure multi-party collaboration and so
much more there are many code labs and
documentation on our website so check
those out as well and then we heard from
Christina about the work of the Privacy
sandbox team that leverages tees to make
the internet even more private and
secure
so I hope you enjoy the presentation
you'll learn something new you got some
cool links